on the Saturday night after Donald from
stunning presidential victory over
Hillary Clinton Saturday Night Live
decided to forgo its mandate in humor in
favor of a full-on political wake kate
mckinnon who has done a creditable job
mocking clinton for most of the election
cycle led off the show with a full
rendition of the recently deceased
Leonard Cohen's Hallelujah there were
zero laughs and lots of delicious
delicious celebrity tears McKenna wasn't
the only one crying by the way Lady gaga
who introduced Clinton in her last pre
election rally apparently wept openly
backstage as Clinton lost on election
night so did Cher
Katy Perry was to overcome she then
skipped singing the national anthem a
nationally donated a bunch of money to
Planned Parenthood for his story Lena
Dunham of girls and bragging about
sexually abusing her sister in her
memoir Fame she penned an open letter
quote I touched my face and realized I
was crying can we please go home I said
to my boyfriend I could tell he was
having trouble breathing and I could
feel my chin breaking into hives at home
I got in the shower and began to cry
even harder my boyfriend would already
wet watched me as I mumbled incoherently
clutching myself to put it mildly or to
put it slightly less mild label let's
spend its time during this election
cycle lecturing Americans from the
Hollywood Hills it didn't work after
years of President Obama traipsing into
studios in LA to read mean tweets after
nearly a decade of listening to the
sophomoric unearned moral superiority of
actors and actresses will earn millions
for reading lines other people right
after watching 9/11 truther rappers go
to the White House Americans said no to
celebrity culture by electing a
celebrity because that's what we do the
great irony of Trump's victories that he
was actually an anti celebrity celebrity
yet all the perks of celebrity but he
reveled in them he didn't try to claim
he was a better human being than the
white middle class voters in Wisconsin
by virtue of living in New York in a
penthouse covered in gold leaf Trump
played the everyman on television and it
worked meanwhile celebrities who didn't
grow up in tremendous wealth hobnob with
the elites singers and actresses taped a
fight song rendition for the DNC Dunham
appeared on stage the convention sounds
her sister Beyonce and jay-z campaigned
for Clinton so did Bruce Springsteen and
all of them did so for a woman whose
closest contact with flyover country
came during one highly
choreograph stop at Chipotle Americans
may never get over their obsession with
celebrity but they sure don't want to
hear those celebrities talk down to them
America has disconnected itself from
rural America and rural Americans were
more than willing to punish Hollywood
for that grave sin if Democrats hope to
win down the road they're gonna have to
do better than trotting out the scornful
glitterati I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show oh so much to get you
today so much to talk about first we
have to say hello to our sponsors over a
wink calm so if you don't know anything
about wine what a good wine is what a
bad wine is but you know kind of what
you like in terms of food and drink then
go to try winked calm try winked calm
it's called winc try wink calm slash Ben
and they get $20 off the way that it
works you go there they do a brief
survey they say kind of what foods do
you like and then they recommend wines
that are based on the kinds of foods you
like and the kind of dinner you're
expecting to have so they do all the
expertise work for you
their wine apparently is really good
everybody the offices tried it they're
all drunk all the time from a wink wine
which is why the podcast is so bad but
try winked calm slash Ben is the place
to go WI and see calming brand their own
why they make it and apparently
according to all the people at the
office it is indeed top notch $20 off
right now and it's personalized to your
palate so it's not just you order in
line it's actually personalized to the
kind of wine that you'll like and it is
pretty spectacular service try wink comm
slash Ben okay
lots and lots to get to today here on
the bench Shapiro show so first of all
got to give you the update from what
happened at DePaul so last night DePaul
University I'm supposed to speak there
and the way that we were working this is
as you recall six months ago there's a
big hubbub at DePaul because Milo you
Napoles spoke at DePaul and a bunch of
the students rushed the stage and they
took over the stage and they were
yelling at him and secure didn't do
anything and and then the administration
decided to fire the presidents of the
university basically for having allowed
that lecture and they issued a blanket
ban not only am i low but on me and I
wasn't even there I didn't do anything
but they didn't like the fact that there
was a riot near riot at Cal State LA
when I spoke there and at Penn State
when I spoke there and they said we just
can't handle this we just can't handle
this so they issue this blanket Ben so
the yellow Americas foundation chapter
they go to the administration they say
we'd like to have Shapiro speak and then
raishin says nah and so instead what
they do is they set up a lecture with
christina hoff sommers who's a wonderful
fabulous human being loved Christina and
she's the anti third wave feminist
professor and they have her come and
speak and she was going to be
accompanied by me so halfway through she
was gonna hand over the microphone to me
and we were gonna do an event to get
around the ban so DePaul finds out about
this a couple of days beforehand and
they say we're gonna shut down the
events unless you ban Shapiro unless you
read ban Shapiro so they say okay well
what if Shapiro just he's already here
what if Shapiro just comes as a guest
and listens to Christina Hoff Sommers
and the administration says no he can't
even be in the room
he can't even come into the room we're
not gonna allow that and they said what
if he comes as a member of Christina's
team like just the people who hang
around with her no they wouldn't allow
that either so the situation yesterday
when I did the podcast was that the
administration was literally threatening
to arrest me if I walked onto campus
they were literally threatening to
arrest me if I walked onto campus so the
way that we worked it was this Christina
went inside the hall and she started her
speech and then I came up afterward
because I wanted to see if these people
were actually serious about shutting
down free speech I'm giving a speech by
the way about free speech right the
speech is actually about free speech and
I wanted to see if they were actually
willing to arrest me turns out they were
because fascism is alive and well on
America's college campuses here is the
the video of what happened last night at
the University well I mean why I have to
inform you that I was coming as a
speaker as a as a person sitting the
audience as well as as a member of
Christina Hoff Sommers is doing so I'm
not sure whether their standards are
necessary I'm also wondering exactly why
it's so necessary to keep me personally
out
well why is your protocol to keep me
specifically out what country protocol
so did you know our United States you
want to stop over here inside well I'm
happy to do it right here if you'd like
the bottom line is it's
what about proper procedures weren't
filed you're not so I might understand
that if I take three steps forward
you'll without to have me arrested if
you create a problem and you won't act
okay so just to be just to be clear if I
attempt you to enter that all right
there and sit down just to listen to
somebody speak or if I attempt to ask a
question or to engage in free speech you
will have me arrested returned to the
point okay I'm glad that we've clarified
that situation I'm also glad that in a
city I mean clearly you have great
security I'm glad in a city that has
some four thousand shootings to this day
we have thirty members of security just
for a five nine eleven sixty five Jewish
guy well okay well if that's how we're
gonna do this and we'll just didn't tell
smart folks crowd and we walked over to
a theater that was about four blocks
away and we did the event there i Skyped
into Christina in the hall and she said
okay everybody up and out everybody got
up walked off that appalled campus and
went somewhere whether were they're not
fascist it is an amazing thing right
wasn't that they were banning me because
I didn't have an RSVP they knew I was
coming
clearly that's why this wasn't like they
weren't aware by the way how many
protesters were there there how many
protesters they had protect the
protesters from me
right and that was the the idea I'm a
very violent person as you come to know
me
over the course of the last year I love
violence so much that I've denounced
every candidate who has engaged in any
violent rhetoric the entire campaign i
but I am a a deep threat I mean I've got
the karate skills so yeah so they were
afraid that I was gonna just start
jumping on people and whaling on them or
something so in any case I go there the
Jewish Chainsaw Massacre I show up and
they literally have thirty security
guards and the sheriff from Cook County
is there as well because the way that
this works legally speaking is campus
security can't actually arrest anybody
they can detain me then they have to
have the sheriff take me to jail so they
actually had brought the sheriff of Cook
County there just for me I felt very
special so they had thirty members of
security plus a sheriff from Cook County
and about five cops we're sitting in a
cop car down the street it's just for
little old me and I have to admit I
never thought of myself as a security
threat that way it's kind of empowering
they thought I was gonna turn into the
Hulk and turn green and wear purple
pants but it is amazing
and again there were this many
protesters this many but there were zero
protesters none not a zilch no
protesters at all but they've
internalized the demands of the rioters
and the protesters so much that they
didn't arrest any of the rioters and
protesters when they destroyed Milo's
Beach six months ago there weren't any
tonight that the administration still
threatened to arrest me if I had tried
to step onto the campus so you know
there are people saying that I should
have gotten myself arrested just for the
shtick of it okay first of all I'm not
going to get arrested just for the sake
of getting arrested because it was clear
they were going to arrest me they had
one of the people there was actually
suggesting the reason that that fellow
you see there the security guy he's
attempting to bring me aside in that
tape is he wanted to get me over onto
the grass off the public walkway he want
to actually have me step over onto the
grass and at that point everybody
tackles I was not interested in doing
that also I was not interested in not
having cameras there cameras or
wonderful day they make clear to
everybody exactly what's going on but
that's the nature of campus fascism in
today's America today I'm scheduled to
speak at University of wisconsin-madison
apparently there are three separate
groups that are going to be doing
protest which is just fine I'm happy to
have protesters that's free speech but
they're also very very upset that the
speech is open to the public apparently
it's gonna be a packed Hall it's like
500 seats and it's supposed to be packed
and they're very upset that members of
the general public want to come and so
lefties are trying to shut down the
event on the grounds that the general
public shouldn't be allowed to come so
that's the way this works now free
speech on college campuses is dead megyn
kelly was kind enough to have me on her
show last night and here's how that
looks here we go again Ben here we go
again it's incredible I mean time after
time these college campuses won't even
let you speak because you get shouted
down by intolerant people when you try
to go and then they say it's a security
concern yeah it really is amazing this
one was actually particularly amazing
because there wasn't a protester
anywhere in sight she had 30 security
people they could beds right exactly so
they actually internalized the the
rioters so well that now they could
actually reflect them back out to the
world their tolerance of anything except
somebody actually giving a speech on the
topic of free speech that is the actual
topic
again the speech that I was giving was
about free speech and their tolerance
enough to ban it so that was exciting
it's unbelievable you were not allowed
to speak about free speech at all this
is what modern day university campuses
have come to not in all cases there's
the University of Chicago that denied
people their safe spaces but in in this
case so you showed up there to make a
point about free speech and you were
arrested now it does this have any
public dollars coming its way this this
university I don't know it's a private
university which is why is it naturally
just attempt to walk right past security
they have a public university then it
would've done so under my First
Amendment rights University so once
they've made clear that I would be
arrested if I took two steps forward
then what I did instead is christina
hoff sommers who joined Mantha sent this
lecture
she actually Skyped me into the lecture
hall and then we told everybody in the
lecture hall to get up and walk out and
we all walked over to a to a theater
that was about three blocks away and did
the event anyway what what do what do
the kids who if there are kids were
protesting young adults your presence
say do you know well I mean III think
that they're just offended by it by
anybody who has a different point of
view
I mean I'm speaking tomorrow at
University of Wisconsin at Madison and
one of the key reasons that they're
protesting apparently a big protests are
planned is because I'm pro-trump
which is weird since I wasn't so it's
making things up yeah they will left to
let controversial figures from the left
come and speak it's just not somebody
who's got strong views from the right
we've seen it's been good for you for
trying thanks for being here okay so it
was fun and games over at University
wisconsin-madison apparently the hubbub
has started this is a letter from a
state senator in Wisconsin you ready for
this this is breaking news state senator
in Wisconsin Duey Stroebel he just wrote
this letter directly to the to the folks
at an estate of at University of
Wisconsin Madison says quote for weeks
the young Americans for freedom at UW
Madison have been meticulously planning
an event with conservative commentator
in New York Times bestselling author ben
shapiro
in recent days the campus conservatives
who come under attack from ultra-left
agitators these liberals have invited
hundreds to a private Facebook page
titled F white supremacy interrupting
ben shapiro now a complaint has been
filed against the order
stating they broke a university policy
by advertising the events the public in
an advising meeting Center for
Leadership & involvement staff advised
the conservatives but student
organization events are open only to the
campus community students faculty and
staff and in order to open an event in
the public a department must sponsor the
staff also informed the students a
portion of the complaint alleges the
group targeted a member of the campus
community by sharing a publicly
available Facebook post while opposing
students are filing frivolous grumbles
to the to the staff
it appears the university is welcoming
to protesters however not members of the
public looking to listen to mr. Shapiro
senators struggle said it is
taxpayer-funded University Madison
should make efforts to have more events
open to the public it is important to
get student organizations have the
ability to without cumbersome red tape
host events to include the public every
time university officials Lobby my
office for more taxpayer resources they
argue how important the school is to the
state student organizations should have
the freedom without fear of complaints
to create a larger discussion within the
broader public community the cfli which
is the the staff should dismiss this
grievances baseless complaints are not
to be used as a weapon against
organizations with different viewpoints
amazing amazing amazing stuff but this
is the way it works on college campuses
look I wasn't for Trump you want to know
why Trump won it he's a bull crap like
this this is the reason Trump won people
just got sick of all the nonsense that
the left was pushing the safe spaces and
the shut it all down the political
correctness all of that nonsense that's
gone by the wayside Americans just
aren't interested in it and more and
that I can certainly appreciate about
the Trump campaign and about the support
for Trump because it is clear that
across the country the left the
fascistic left is interested in shutting
down anything remotely resembling
freedom of discussion now along those
lines and now along those lines I think
that it is important to note that the
media continue to make absolute asses of
themselves it is amazing yeah again I
keep saying it because I think that it's
important to point out where my biases
are I'm not a person who backed Donald
Trump in the primaries or in the general
election so when I say to the media are
targeting Trump I think that you can
take that with full honesty right I
don't have an interest in propping up in
propping up Trump I have an interest in
him succeeding as a conservative that
would be great
but I don't have an interest in in
biessing for him and so many others do
when I see the media are out to get this
guy they are out to get this guy and
there
doing it in stupidest possible way so
for example Chris Matthew let me say
Matt comes out I show get them they're
mine right studio Nate looks and looks
at telepresence I my god John buttons
gonna be secretary said it's crazy
jump bug check out my leg jump but he's
got a mustache kind of mustache it'll
take a walrus Chris Matthews I'm at the
BC go Trump watch November 14 2016
I can feel much of the country's mood
right now on Saturday Night Live Kate
McKinnon saying Leonard Cohen's
Hallelujah and then again on church on
Sunday night the choir sang it again
because much of America is at a soulful
mood right now but some it's alright
we're actually downright scared our son
was marching in this weekend protest
against the election and through this
right through this I try harder to do
this job and tonight I worry about the
talk that John Bolton might be Trump's
choice for Secretary of State pickin
Bolton would have an immediate effect we
vastly increased the number of people
who were sad at what happened last
Tuesday and the number of people who are
downright scared okay everybody bring
this ball guy who's moustaches crazy
hair I mean look at me
just let me finish let me finish it says
so right on the screen let me finish I
want to finish because Maddie's
everybody say make lipstick are your
thing Kathleen get the hotel room ready
I'm coming home stick my head under a
pillow I'm gonna never shower because
that was not my hair too much gotta
brush her the show
goodness Matthews man okay so the point
there of course is that I love this
Donald Trump is scaring up a John Bolton
is the one who's truly scaring people it
will vastly increase the number of
people who I is sad oh god no not
sadness and some where Donald Trump is
going like I care about you sadness you
tears nourish me yes is but this is the
point the media are so ridiculous that
they if they're suggesting that
Americans are going to be deeply deeply
upset about the appointment of John
Bolton Secretary of State the former UN
Ambassador under george w bush this is
just nuts it's just nuts but the problem
is this the media treated every
conservative proposal for the last 15
years really since since bush was left
in 2002 now them up and as evil and as
Hilarion and so now they just have to
keep upping the answer
there's an order to up the ante I mean
Trump is as bad as it's going to get for
them in terms of somebody who they hate
but they're still trying to up the ante
to John Bolton it just doesn't wash it
doesn't wash it's like what these
protesters are trying to do with these
campuses Donald Trump super super scary
but Shapiro's even scarier in what world
in what no one believes that what are
you talking about okay that's just what
aspect of the media losing their mind
and destroying their own credibility
here's another one the media lost their
mind yesterday because Donald Trump
ditched them and went out to dinner with
his family at a steak house okay so
there's something called I guess the
emergency press pool and what that means
that there's always somebody from the
press traveling with Trump in case
there's an emergency but let's say that
he were out to dinner and suddenly there
were a nuclear attack or something okay
first of all he's the president-elect he
can't do anything yet he's just the
president-elect but he ditches them and
he goes to have a steak dinner and the
media lose their minds like Americans
care about this here are the media just
going nuts over it isn't like just left
without telling pretty much anyone
anything is that right that is correct
his breast pool was given a lid for the
evening which normally suggests that
Donald Trump isn't going anywhere he's
sticking around Trump Tower but Trump
apparently had other plans he decided to
go out to dinner without alerting some
of his key staffers as well as the press
and it appears to be yet another
misunderstanding of exactly how much
gravity use new title as president elect
holds you know if god forbid something
were to happen to him that is a matter
not only of public record but also a
matter of national security given that
he is next in line to take the White
House well indeed it may he seems like
and then Rachel Maddow does the same
thing it is they're all going nuts of it
is how could it possibly be how could we
possibly what Donald Trump get out of
our sights what a terrible
no one cares you know how many people in
America care that Rachel Maddow and crew
couldn't shadow Donald Trump at the
dinner what do you thinks gonna happen
he's gonna get there he's gonna be like
cats be a one-size right now and then
someone doesn't pass the a1 sauce breaks
it off into a jagged edge then shoves it
and they're in their jugular and then
you got some peach before he's oh and
this is just silly talk it's a yeah
that's not even the limit of it in one
moment believe it or not you're gonna
have to hear me defend Steve Bennett I
know I can't believe it either but
that's what this media has come to all
talk about that in just a second but
first I have to give a shout out to our
sponsors over at birchgold.com so
birchgold.com if you're concerned about
the future of the country
if you are concerned that the defendant
is going to raise interest rates the
stock market is inflated the real estate
markets inflated then you need to go
over my friends at birchgold.com / Ben
it's birchgold.com / ben a plus rating
from the Better Business Bureau they'll
teach you how to invest in precious
metals and they will also help you get
that then put your precious metals from
a four we get out of your 401k if you
want to and put it in precious metals
tax-free ask all your questions make
sure that you have all your questions
answered and then invest with my friends
over at birchgold.com / then okay before
we take off I just have to make one
quick note about one more quick note
about the media the media have Oprah /
wildly overplayed their hands on Steve
ban and so as one of the leading ban and
critics in America okay somebody who
worked with Steve ban and for years I
think that Steve Bannon is a is a
vicious very bad guy I think Steve
Bannon is vindictive I think he likes to
destroy people I think it's what he
loves to do I think he also used
Breitbart as a as a way to ingratiate
himself with Trump to the point where he
undercut his own reporters and I think
that he used he was happy to allow
Breitbart to pander to the alt-right and
the alt-right as I've said a thousand
times on the show the alt-right are
people who believe that the Constitution
the Declaration of Independence those
are passe and instead what we need is a
Eurocentric white nationalism so does
that mean that if he is an anti-semite
notice I mean Breitbart is a white
nationalist site no it doesn't it means
that they've pandered to white
nationalists in in some of their writing
and in some of the things that they do
if candidates and some of the people who
are warm to Richard Spencer and Jared
Taylor in that group does that mean the
entire site is white nationalist now of
course not doesn't mean that the entire
site is a reflection of the dare no it
doesn't and but the media can't help
themselves they can't help themselves so
instead of just saying here's what
troubles me about banning the hollowing
out of traditional conservatism
traditional constitutional conservatism
in favor of European far-right populism
which doesn't care about the size of
government which doesn't worry about the
Scots size and scope of government it
just worries most specifically about
shutting down the borders and increasing
tariffs that's all they care about
European far-right populism if that is a
problem for you right they don't but
they're not
now right they're not criticizing that
aspect abandoned they're not criticizing
the aspect abandon that he's really
vicious and that he may use the
government as a method of going after
old enemies considering that he he's
again one of the most more vindictive
people in the business no instead they
have to go full Hitler they have to go
full Hitler and we'll explain all of
that if you go over to Daley wire.com
slash but if you go over to Daley wire
come right now and you subscribe become
a subscriber it's eight dollars a month
and that allows you also get rid of all
the ads on the site which is pretty cool
eight dollars a month allows you access
to the rest of this show live it allows
the rest of Andrew Clayton's show live
it allows you to become part of the
mailbag and if you get an annual
subscription right now you still get a
signed copy of my new novel true
allegiance so check that out right now
over at over at our website daily
wire.com become a subscriber become part
of the team part of the largest
conservative podcast in America
you